Let's pick up on our caller from the six five
zero area code.
Who's calling today from six five zero.
Hey David, this is Tyler calling.
Hey Tyler, what's up?
Technical pleasure.
Hey, so, um, I was just calling because you
know, I've been hearing a lot of conversation
about like the transgender, um, athletes sort
of issue where it's like sort of like amplified
a lot in media recently.
Like, and you know, there was like the South
park episode that just happened where they,
they got a lot of flack for that.
And um, I was just curious to know like what,
how you respond to people when they, when
they ask you about this issue.
And I'm sure you've probably talked about
it before, but you know, I, I haven't had
a chance to hear your thoughts on it and I,
I value your, your opinion and just curious
to know what you, how you respond to that.
So
here's my thought.
The reason that the particularly the right
is focusing on the trans athlete issue is
because it's the only way that they can try
to get people to even be open to their side
on the issue of how society should treat trans
people.
Right?
So when you look at all of these other issues,
is it a detriment to society that someone
born biologically male, uh, gets to, um, uh,
express what might be a female gender expression
by getting a license that says female?
No, it's fine.
Like going to be fine.
Uh, our trans people who are allowed to use
the bathroom that matches their gender identity,
uh, looking to go and, you know, pray on children
or whatever, it's like, no, that's not an
issue.
So the only way they can make any headway
is by saying, Hey, if you're born biologically
male, you really shouldn't be.
In a female weight lifting class and it's
like, okay, that's fine.
We can, I wouldn't even disagree with them.
It's just not [inaudible].
It's not the issue.
It's not the, it has nothing to do with how
society should be treating trans people.
Even issues like middle school soccer, like
my sister is in high school, her school only
has a coed soccer team and they will play
against all boys teams.
They will play against coed teams.
And it's like, okay, they're at a disadvantage
when they play against the boys teams.
They're allowed to have a, you know, fuel
for your girls on the field.
But it's like nobody's life is being altered
by this in any significant way.
And you can find these edge cases of, of track
or weightlifting and the Olympics.
It's just, it's not really the issue.
And they want to put the focus on it because
it's the only one where, where they can really
even have any argument.
Yeah.
I 100% agree with you.
And it's really discouraging when like, you
know, I listened to like you and, um, you
know, the whole bunch of other, um, um, like
podcasters and uh, or if you want to call
it that.
But, um, you know, like I listen to Joe Rogan
sometimes and it's really unfortunate to hear
how he harps on, on that issue, like ad nauseum
made every episode.
And I know he's like, has a huge platform
and I'm sure that definitely, you know, amplifies
that message.
And I mean, it's just, it's just kinda discouraging
to hear like that being talked about out of
all the different things that are going on
in the world and it's like, come on, like,
yeah.
So, um, thank you for you know, that, that,
that definitely answers, you know what I was
kind of looking for, just to kinda hear that,
appreciate it.
And, you know, I'd love to go back on Joe's
show anytime and would be glad to discuss
it with him and, and uh, I think, uh, that
would be, that would be useful.
All right.
Thank you so much for the call.
I very much appreciate hearing from you.